okay let's talk about something a little
lighter because we've had a lot of
really bad and disturbing news over the
weekend and on the bonus show today I'm
going to talk about some of the not
great things that took place during my
weekends in Montreal and I haven't even
told Pat about these so I think he's
gonna find it compelling I would predict
we've had a long sort of path of the
David Pakman show soundtrack the music
that's on the show over the last many
many years and we used to use commercial
music like just songs that were in the
sort of commercial space that we liked
and as the show got bigger it became
sort of too much of a risk of copyright
issues to keep just pulling songs off of
the Billboard Hot 100 that we like and
using them on the show so what we've
been doing is rotating through different
audience created music so for a while
here we had music by nathan michael mark
uzi and more recently we had music we
have music from currently Jay the handle
of of one of our longtime members and
viewers who is the composer of some of
the music that we now happen as usual
some people like the music we have some
people hate the music we have people
threatened to stop listening to the show
because they hate the music so much we
kind of have to use our own judgement in
the end because someone will always hate
it music so personal I danced that music
before every show every single day
that's my routine and then we start it's
part of why actually our lease is not
being renewed in this space because the
management is seen that doing that but
that's probably we want to keep that on
the bonus show so anyway we're looking
at another update right and it's not for
any negative reason it's not because of
Pat's dancing to the current theme it's
not because we don't like what we have
but over time we like to keep things
current and update the music on the show
and it came to my attention through our
subreddit that an artist who goes by the
name of chosen and has created a song
called contemporary American which
samples a whole bunch of people at
samples me and Howard Dean Kyle from
secular talk bill o'reilly jordan
peterson sam cedar a whole bunch of
different people and what i want to
present to you is we're gonna listen to
just a little bit of this song in a
second i want to present to you whether
we should look at contacting chousen
to see and it might be that that it's
actually chosen but it's spelled in a
funny way I don't know but
I'm saying chosen I kind of like the
sound of it we might contact chousen and
say hey could we use this song or
another version of it that's loving
chosen for the theme song for the show
okay so let's take a listen to it
together and see what we think you heard
my voice they're part of the sample I
think that if people like this we would
need to contact chousen and see about
commissioning a version of this song
where it's all samples from the show
because I don't know about whether some
of these other shows like that the
Howard Dean clip is sort of in the
public domain at this point I would say
yeah but later they get to clips from
other shows where it might not actually
be okay to use it as our opening set
Howard Dean scream is pretty legendary
yes point I wouldn't be opposed to
having that included in our theme music
right but some of the other stuff I feel
like just like the melody and the beat
it ties into the show a little bit you
think so I think it I think it
correlates yeah alright well listen
we'll see what people think is that
something that should be a candidate for
the next theme song I also want to
mention that so people may know that Stu
Brooks the bassist for Matisyahu and
from dub trio and who has played bass
for every such luminaries as Tupac
Shakur and many others he is a fan of
the David Pakman show and he's a friend
of mine and he has said we have an
open-door policy to using any dub trio
music we want for the show and I hope
that he hasn't without telling me
retracted that offer but maybe I'll text
them after the show but that's another
possibility which is maybe dub trio
music could be music for the program and
that range is all sorts of different
genres so I don't know we're starting to
think about the next thing
musically for the program but I don't
know if it's gonna be chosen song
contemporary American or something from
dub trio or what its going to be but
we're exploring all options I think is
the message yeah it could just be me
playing an acoustic guitar singing some
folk song who knows it could be yes
let's leave it at that